everyone this is kevin from the chess
website.com and today we're in round 3
of the 2016 candidates tournament raced
for the world championship winner of
this tournament gets to play Magnus
Carlsen in November for the crown our
competitors in round 3 why it's gonna be
played by to applaud had kind of a rough
start round one against fishing on just
way out prepared vision on went on to
take that one and then around 2 got a
draw now this is the first game of this
14 round series that he has the white
pieces so looking to really bounce back
here as opponent today it's gonna be
Levon Aronian who has to draw so far in
the tournament and so blob starts out
with pons has he board it's kind of
interesting you don't see the English
opening that often especially from top
lot but what what is interesting to note
is the last time these players faced off
December 2015 so just a few months ago
in the London Chest Classic the only
game that LeMond Aronian one was against
au poivre and he played the English
opening and so a lot of the preparation
that goes into these tournaments is for
specific players and no doubt that oak
lava remembers that game and he's been
thinking about different positions in
that board state and so he came prepared
this is the first time that he's got to
play the white pieces and so definitely
looking for him to use this maybe some
secrets awesome one variation that he
has here but the English opening against
Levon Aronian we'll go ahead and get
into it after pawn to c4 we see Knight
f6 Knight to c3 pawn here to e5 Knight
to f3 Knight here to c6 so back in
December look the London chess classic
we had a three Knights game in this
particular case we're gonna see the for
Knight game now Levon Aronian didn't
have to play knight c6 he had some other
options if you kind of look at it pawn
to e4 does look somewhat tempting
although it's really not as good as it
looks
Knight g5 all of a sudden both of these
Knights attacking this pawn here on e4
really no strong way for black to really
deal with this but decides to go ahead
and play Knight to c6 pawn here g3
getting ready to fee and keshu on the
King side Bishop b4 bishop here to G to
Fink NO on at the Kings side Cass on the
King
Knight d5 someone interesting move
usually you're gonna see castle on the
kingside for white just kind of hang
this knight on c3 but decides to go
ahead and play a little bit interesting
move Knights
d5 now pawn to e4 it's a little bit
different now because if the knight were
to come to g5 there's no longer two
Knights attacking this now we could just
see the knight take on d5 we can see the
pond recapture all of a sudden the Queen
comes down here to g5 take pawn captures
here pawn takes here on c6 all of a
sudden blacks got a pretty good spot
here this bishops kind of tied down
can't really do anything because of the
pawns this pawn can't move would you'd
really like to it's kind of awkward for
this King to go anywhere
if the bishop does take up here on e4
then all of a sudden this bishop can
come to h3
and this is even worse for white now we
really can't castle on at the Kings side
just applying a lot of pressure onto the
board he does try you pawn a3 trying to
kick this Bishop back Bishop here to a5
if you were to push forward what you
know you probably wouldn't because this
is a bad move but just so y'all can kind
of see punt up here
b4 all of a sudden Queens to e5 is just
devastating attacking both the bishop
and the rook on a1 so all in all not
very good at all so as we come back here
we can definitely see that the Knights
coming there to a g5 no longer really a
viable option so we see Knights h4 pawn
here to a d6 just opening up the door
for the light square bishop to get
involved into the game nice back here a
b4 Knight capturing here on b4 pawn a3
forcing the knight back and Knight to c6
pawn here to d3 pawn here to d5 and
that's where it kind of gets a little
interesting on the board up into this
point taupe lava it looks like he's been
pretty prepared for this opening he's
had a few months they've had the
schedule he knew who who he was playing
in round 3 I've kind of been waiting
forward to see how he was gonna come out
the blocks after his loss in the London
chest classic so he knows this position
very well he decided to go ahead and
castle on
the kingside I don't really like it that
well it allows your opponent so it kind
of dictates the tone of the game I would
have much rather just see pawn takes
here on e4 pawns gonna recapture efore
Bishop here to g5 why it's kind of
pretty aggressive stance right here
if the Queen's come off the board that's
fine on board but instead decides to go
ahead and play castle on the Kings side
and after the pawn takes the Queen's
gonna recapture I think even if you're
gonna recapture recapturing with the
pawn makes a lot more sense after a pawn
takes on d3 Bishop e6 rook e1
threatening this long efile right here
pawn takes on c4 pawn recaptures Bishop
captures but if we kind of look at it
that it's not terrible for whites all of
a sudden we could play Queen c2 this is
threatening both the bishop and if the
bishop moves then all of a sudden the
bishop can attack on c6 double pawns
here the Queen can put a lot of pressure
on they're still not the best I would
rather just see you know that pawn
capture earlier on d4 as we talked about
but all in all we see the pawn capture
here on d3 and then Queen takes on d3
the main problem I don't like with Queen
to d3 is night C v is really tough to
deal with the Queen now has to move
Queen to d4 now Knight takes on c4 and
black septum aterial usually you don't
see black game this much material unless
white just has a huge attack but white
really doesn't have a huge attack right
now we see pawn up here to e4 Bishop e6
holding down the fort here both the
bishop Queen and Knight are all
protecting this square here on d5 now we
see pawn b3 just forcing the knight back
that's fine we see the knight come back
to a5 now Queen over here to a4 knight
c6 that's fine
rook to d1 it rook to d1 even scent
seems a little weird you know trying to
add more pressure on this square here on
d5 but it's just so well protected with
the knight the bishop and the Queen this
isn't doing a whole heck of a lot I
think it would have been a
stronger opposed to try you know pawn
takes on d5 after the Knight takes then
all of a sudden Bishop here to be to
still down the material but I like this
board state more than what we had so
after rook d1 we see Knight take on e4
which I'm at was sure if he recognized
the his opponent could just take that
right now and then he plays Bishop to b2
also don't like this you can see I
didn't really like how to bluff started
out this game Bishop here to be - I
think taking here on e for the pawn
can't recapture right now because the
Queen would fall so this kind of forces
a Queen to f6 so getting some material
on board you can really start to make
some headway does have the double bishop
pair so he has some options on board but
Bishop here to be - Queen here to e7
pawn up here to be for if we kind of
look at it black is just dominating it
really hasn't done anything too exciting
but he's up to pawns on board he
controls the center of the board
both of these double bishop pairs are
this double bishop pair is not really
doing too much on Topol offside Aronian
suing a great job of just clogging up
every potential the Queen over here on a
four is not really in tandem with any of
the other pieces you know this rook is
not doing too much trying to control the
center but doesn't really have any of
the support that he needs so all in all
top off has a rough start in black doing
a fairly good job of taking the English
opening this opponent probably prepared
for a long time and is completely just
dominating we now see black play pawn a
six Queen back here to a c2 just
attacking the side of the night in the
center of the board pot f6 look over
here to see one finally getting that
rook involved into the action rook here
to d8 just putting more defenders on the
center of the board this d5 pawn has
been hugely advantageous for black in
the stern of the board with this outpost
here on e4 as well bishop f1 rook here
to d7 and black just really trying to
improve position and then over time just
start to exchange material off the board
pawn f3
that's fine night here to d6 rook of
to e1 Queen f7 bishop here to d3 opening
up the door to attack the square here on
h7 that's fine pawn down here to a g5
really nice move not only defends the
square with the Queen and the rook both
defending h7 but also is kind of a
counter-attack with the pawn
forcing this knight on h4 to move so
Knight back here to g2 now Knight coming
in with a c4 attacking this bishop right
here decides to go and let it slide so
Knight takes on b2 now also attacking
this Bishop right here Queen takes and
now Bishop down here to h3 getting ready
to exchange with this night here on a g2
after pawn to a4 we see pawn age 6 this
is kinda one of those questionable moves
it seemed like Levon Aronian had a clear
plan there's no real reason to bring
your Bishop down here to h3 unless
you're just gonna exchange it off the
board he can easily just take right here
Bishop takes on g2 b5 pawn takes on b5
pawn recaptures this is a really good
spot you just move your knight really
really good or you could just even move
your bishop if you really wanted to but
the sets go and play for in my opinion
kind of a head-scratcher move of h6 he's
still up on the material but there's
just no reason to play down here at h3
if you're not gonna take that material
pawn up here to b5 pawn takes pawn
recaptures a knight back here to e7 so
it doesn't look like he wants to hold on
to that material Queen over here f2
Knight to f5 just starting to put all
the pressure over here on the King side
of the board Queen to f3 King hear g5
king h1 rook d7 after the exchange on
the board that's fine Queen to h5 looks
like it's trying to attack this Bishop
here on h3 but it almost just forces
LeMond to run Ian's a hand to go ahead
and take that piece here on d2 that the
Queen just wasn't doing he has no
additional helpers to have any sort of
attack he's not really representing much
of a threat at all so we kind of look at
the board state here you know if this
palm wasn't here he can maybe get past
it because he
the bishop right here but all in all
that the Queen was kind of a just a
wasted move to bring up here to h5 and
now it's completely separated from the
rest of the board say so after night to
III check of King comes back here upon
two f5 now Queen down here to e2
threatening this night's rook here to f6
this is one of those I think Levon
Aronian could have played a little bit
better this Knight is protected by the
Queen right here but would really like
to get the Queen involved into the
attack it is the strongest piece we are
now in the endgame you don't want your
most important piece just playing
defense duty pawn to d4 seems like the
the clear winner can't be chased off
it's on a dark square lights where
bishop can't make it go anywhere you
know if your opponent wants to give up
one of his big pieces to get this Knight
removed that's fine but this is probably
the best outpost that he could ever come
up with on this board state now his
Queen can kind of roam free do it every
once to his rook and get involved into
the game so while he's still completely
dominating his opponent I do think d4 is
a much better play in this position but
decides to go and play rook f6 Queen
here to a b2 just pinning down this rook
to the king that's no problem we'll see
the pawn take after the pawn takes King
to h7 it doesn't really matter this
Queen still protecting this rook so that
is fine as well King h1 Queen g7 Queen
e2 now pawn to d4 so he did eventually
find it and this is completely fine he
does want to get that Queen involved
into the game as we talked about Queen
f3 c6 he had a lot of ways that he would
have gone about this rook to b6 that was
fine as well but decides to go ahead and
stop the attack here both the Queen and
the the pawn we're kind of ganging up on
these light squares so after the
exchange on board the rook is now
protecting this pawn as well so blacks
being both aggressive and still holding
down the fort with his defenses very
nicely pawn h3 a rook here to g6 rook to
a b1 rook down here to g3 forcing the
Queen's move Queen h5
not doing a whole lot Queen d7 King up
here to h2 now the attack with the
defense from this night just such a good
place for that night King here - h1 and
then Queen down here a d5 getting ready
for a discovered attack there's no place
the king can really move here and then
after the rook moves there is gonna be a
discovered attack so the rook can just
kind of gobble up any material if he
wants to come over here to d2 he can
even come up here to g5 that pawn can't
take it he's gonna have to play defense
all in all just completely lost calls
for white and it even got worse and
worse towards the end of the game so
congratulations even though sometimes
players don't play well I always like to
give props to the winter so Levon
Aronian play the black pieces against
the tough opponents always always feels
good to get the win as a black pieces so
a total of having a rough start to the
tournament losing two of the first three
rounds is gonna be tough to make up to
be honest he's a very strong player so
surprising to see him play at this point
but hopefully he has a good rest of the
tournament he can kind of bounce back
and we have him near the top of the
leaderboard but for the fans out there
champ for him unfortunately he is not
doing so well so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this game really good defense
from Levon Aronian and I'll see you guys
in the next one